a warm welcome for the Commission
President on the day of his first-ever
state the Union address mr. younger
began by talking over Europe in bad
shape unable to face up to his current
date challenge all of us we should
remember well that you'd is a continent
where nearly everyone has at one time
being a refugee it is true that Europe
cannot house all the misery of the world
we are fighting against the Islamic
state why are we not ready to accept
those who are fleeing the Islamic state
Monsieur Anka called a member states to
respect his son in procedure he also
called for a list of safe countries
which drawn up to help fast-track
refugees adding that illegal migration
package would be unveiled in early 2016
so what was the response from the
chamber he makes this no monitor
striking 50 Christie McGraw TG fraction
filipino me at least my upbringing is in
De Niro punished Ulster of the sphere
rest if you Kristen Kristen HD a phenom
using the narrow path all stuff that we
are mentioned rested a fountain home
vadaulious aerial volta del Presidente
concilio robayo rhetoric Amenti parlando
para also meant a key a casa de tarde
Nellis post a rope a non che soul
immigration a camellia detto la ropa
david Turner afar la ropa the sentiment
of solidarity rang all around Europe
does not need a new Iron Curtain Europe
needs iron will but let's be clear
telling countries what to do forcing a
plan on them only risks more
finger-pointing for the Liberals certain
countries needed to be told what not to
do is Budapest what we see incredible
refugees heard it in a train station
treated I have to tell without any
respect and then we say ok let's open
the balls let's say let's put a number
of of the railway open the railway a
little bit so that they can go to
Austria that it can go to Mecca
everything ok the problem is over well
such an attitude is disgrace
fall for Europe and then something a
little bit different issue understood
sir of hidden file a la foto MV dolphin
oslo fantasy le gala ionizer mukesh
chitin I'd mandolins mukesh cardan shaft
mersin dances in fear and easily Darvish
ohio don't give most andaz vanished by
an aquatic lonstein blind ed
individuelle bitterness the individual
names but earnest of fun mention other
calf said no papa zodanga sitesi da
sogno di palermo hopia perfec Marty keep
som is a disposition por la que todo
hair domi ha ido refugee Iglesias create
a Tony Abu cellular Tony say say there
isn't right it seemed were less
enthusiastic either feeling that the
British people will warm to you on a
personal level but to suggest but
getting rid of a few EU regulations is
going to change our minds sorry unless
you give Mr Cameron back control and
discretion over our borders the Brits
within the course of the next year will
vote to leave righto fantasmic noticed
see pathetic mo vicinity Toledo secreto
new disco chali tada Luneta nice check
the anticipation can you open autumn ha
na li xue bao listo para democracy
parallel fandom j espere sacamos hoshino
semi britannique le papillon following
Sean Zuko net cost elite a security demo
Cassie epic in mr. yonkers own words it
wasn't an entire state of the union but
his and Europe's focus was for now on
one thing mr. president to create any
illusions that the refugee crisis will
be over anytime soon it will not and we
have to know that but pushing back boats
from Pierce setting fire to refugee
camps or turning a blind eye to poor and
helpless people that is not Europe
oops